after a while man like where i'm at i
just want to i've been blessed to make a
a lot of money
and my willingness
you know it's a blessing to be there
and make this money but it's a also a
courage that i haven't
finally i've got property i bought a
house um you know
i bought my wife franchise we finally
got that going we we i want to take the
money that's god bless me with too i get
i don't have to work break my back to do
it to leave something uh some kind of
inheritance as hell because i could get
like deja pal of course i should be and
i should have a lot of [__] with if i
got deja pal money but right now i've
got level money and i could make a lot
of a lot of doors because i used to i
knew a comic he's a preacher down here
now
very good dude
and uh
you know i
i'm [__] listen his name now cause
i'm because because i'm i'm grown and i
brought his name up i'm sitting there
rodney the rodney and his name is rodney
and uh rodney but
i don't think his last name before he
still does comedy or doesn't he no he's
a
preacher i don't think i don't think
he's gonna stop the comedy no more but
but rodney told me
he was a touring comic okay
rodney bought four houses
rodney had nexuses he he used his money
that he got and he invested but he was a
military guy he got out of military he
got married he got divorced and he went
to a uh
different steps in his life to be where
he is
and it's
incredible that he he had told me you
just gotta invest your money hold it you
take the moneys that you get and man i i
was a promoter i made money then there i
mean i had i've i already
showed you what kind of money i got
i gotta
i wish i had some of that money but the
thing about squandering your
squandering your squandering squandering
your money because i didn't have nobody
to show me how to do it i had an uncle
to tell me that's what you should do but
he didn't show me because i'm not i'm
not a dumb person but i i need someone
to guide me is that the uncle that was a
clown
do you have an uncle it's a clown
in my research i had that that you have
an uncle that was a clown maybe you were
clowning on your uncle
maybe you're like he's a clown like he's
not really like yeah he ain't like that
like that he clowned dang i tried to do
a deep cut on that one i tried i tried
to go deep on these interviews i tried
to pull
he used to be a funny [__] man
yeah i mean he keeps the statements on
his mind he did he had a lot of fun and
[__] happened to him
he's always been a funny dude you know
but you're talking about all this money
though but you know i'll go headline up
in maryland for you know 200 bucks
so like that that's where i'm at right
now dude i've been i've been there of
course then i've gone and done like
other gigs for five grand
my way through canada came back with 175
dollars that's cancer wine i've done i
was in bemidji minnesota i done all
these places and i came back 175
wow
hey hey if gas was cheap thank god that
was cheap but i i didn't make no money
i've done
i've done a lot of things for [__]
free yeah
i remember the first gig i got for 250
freaking dollars and my head gasket blew
off blew up on my car and i had to use a
whole 250 to get a coffee
i did that with my alternator before
yeah yeah yeah
i mean but 200
yeah it's the you know when i i didn't
even know how to get paid at comedy at
one time
but i loved doing it because i was
getting i get free snacks for [__]
drinks i had a good time getting on
stage and i you know meeting people
it was it was that was the moments you
know that i that i have missed
you know what i'm saying now
everybody get it it's like i didn't get
to a point where i i'm flying
but everybody that i used to be
on the ground with
they i still love them but they don't
talk to me the same this clip is one of
hundreds we have here at hop breath so
click right here to subscribe and check
them out
and then jump to this video i picked
just for you
sorry about the eyebrows